I have a couple of problems first of all
the last couple of two weeks in the last
couple of weeks I've had a cold and I
was planning on doing loads of videos
and doing all this commentary over all
this recorded footage that I had so I
didn't have this big delay anymore
between recording something and actually
releasing it because right now it is
still over a week that I've recorded
this way over a week actually at this
point and instead of actually you know
reaching that point where I make a video
and then I come and say over it and then
I release it it's actually gone worse
because this is way this is recorded way
over a week ago and that is a bit of an
issue because in this video I'll be
tackling a couple of things that I've
actually tackled a long time ago such as
the office zones which will all be
placed in industrial complexes of course
because that was a problem that I was
running into and didn't really realize
that I had to replace all my office
zones with industrial zones and then
there's also the fact that by the time
that I am saying this the entire area in
the middle of the city is changed in a
way but I'm not going to give that away
yet because you'll all see that in the
future and hopefully the soon future
because even though my cold is not
entirely over I feel like I'm good
enough to commentate again even though
this is definitely not the best idea I
went to sleep way past 3:00 a.m. last
night and I still have that cold and
this is definitely the ideal situation
to stream but I would like to say that
it's also a positive thing because I've
been playing more role occurs again
three again and they're working on a lot
of things and even the let's play park
while I wasn't even recording that but I
probably shouldn't be talking about that
I broke I should probably be talking
about what I'm doing in this video right
now well this neighborhood right here is
the bucharest area which that big square
in the middle is going to be the park
it's got about a communistic idea you
know that having a big park in the
middle of your neighborhood and then
placing all this housing around that
very much planned and structured but I
still do like the area for that and it
turned out pretty nice in the end but
you'll see that in a bit
and you also see that this video is
actually pretty short and I wasn't
originally planning on that but it just
turned out this way because the episode
after this is going to be the big show
of episode it which I'm actually go to
look at the city and look at what I've
got and it's a good thing I suppose that
before that episode is there I'm still
going to change many of the problems
that I still have in the city and here
it goes that's part of the big
industrial complex over there being
completely demolished to make room for
office zones and a bit of in dust I mean
not industrial no not that all the
commercial and residential zones though
I must say that neighborhood is kind of
turning into something that I would not
like to live in it is pretty functional
and it's not causing the massive traffic
problems that the industrial complexes
caught so yeah I think it's a good
change in the end and this is just
problems that I had in the downtown with
traffic and I don't know if I'm actually
having traffic problems or not because
on one hand there are still quite some
red roads but I'm not really seeing any
traffic jams so I'm not really sure
whether I can claim that my traffic is
very smooth and good or whether I
actually do have congestion it's hard to
say where the line is between congestion
and just heavy traffic use but I guess
there's a lot of heavy traffic use but
not really too bad although you can see
and that's the reason that I decided to
make this other highway ramp over here
that a couple of highway ramps have been
are being used way too often and this
eventually led to the fact that due to
these two highway ramps being edits it
almost looks as if there are too many
highway ramps for know such a small city
and every half a kilometer even less
than that
you'll have another highway ramp and it
always seems like I have too many of
these things but this is how many I need
to prevent the congestion and not really
sure if this is unrealistic it probably
is but I guess that's just how the
traffic works and how I have to deal
with it and that's a good thing and a
bad thing because you know it's a
challenge to work your way around
traffic problems but sometimes you'll do
extremely unrealistic things to do well
fix the problems just like I did just
now I wanted to build that ramp but
there were houses over there
and you can without a problem just
remove any house that's in the way or
completely flatten and tie your
neighborhoods to build your highways on
and you know it's it's nice when you're
playing the game because you don't have
those pesky people complaining about
your plans that are obviously just about
the economic growth of the city but then
again it's not really realistic in that
sense I'd expect to have at least
Greenpeace complaining about the fact
that I am removing nature and city to
build my enormous high where he's
everywhere and just straight-out
demolishing people without the
demolishing people the demolishing
people's houses without their permission
just to build a highway ramp seems to be
a bit of an evil thing to do but I can
do that in this game and it was really
greater good I'd say in this case and as
you can see this neighborhood is growing
into a shitty neighborhood it's looks
terrible honestly it's definitely not
something that I would want to live in
on the contrary this neighborhood which
is later going to be known as Bucharest
is pretty nice is that kind of planned
neighborhood and I'm kind of divided
about those things because on one hand I
do like the organic growth but then
again cities are planned at least over
here they are planned so it feels like
the best way to deal with this is to
have a certain kind of planning that is
functional and looks somewhat planned
but also very organic I don't want to
have a completely straight road system
and I don't want the city to be a
perfect working metropolis kind of like
the perfectly planned metropolis is that
many people built in Sim City that were
well-functioning and perfect in many
senses but just looking like a dystopian
kind of city that I would not want
and that's something I want to avoid so
I want to find that balance between a
good city and a good looking city which
in my case would be a organic but also
kind of plant city now one thing that I
am somewhat yea uncertain about is my
very round Road pattern because this
road pattern has many more curves than
any real city in the world would have I
mean even the city center has all those
sub urban roads which is which seems to
make sense of course because in the
beginning it was actually a suburb ish
kind of place but right now it's
actually grown and has flats and big
offices and it doesn't really seem to
fit the curvy roads anymore so that's
something I will look into in the future
and possibly remove some curves and make
the roads more straight because you know
as cool as the curves are and as curvy
as many roads are in Europe this is
probably taking it too far
and even in the case of organic growth
this probably wouldn't happen so I'm
going to look into that and here we see
the district making of Bucharest it is
it even called Bucharest anymore I don't
know and there's also that fine little
church which I was quite fond of in the
beginning because that was one of the
only churches in the workshop at the
time but right now the workshop is
flooded with so many buildings and
definitely a lot very different from
when I just got this thing and so much
has changed and so much custom content
is being added that I am afraid that at
some point that nobody will be able to
take all the custom content and
especially the game won't be able to
take it but I guess we'll see I am
actually looking forward to seeing all
that stuff develop and it's really
awesome to see so many custom things
already in the beginning monies of this
game but yeah I must say by the way that
those roofs of the offices are also big
and white doesn't really look too great
and now I suddenly get all these big
areas with white buildings and
everything not too sure about how I'm
actually going to do that or if I want
to restructure all those areas but yeah
that's it for this episode and I'll see
you on the next episode which is going
to be completely different because we're
gonna do
nice tour of the city look at what I've
got so far
so